[Music]
kim kardashian makes her big debut at
paris fashion week and the skims founder
is owning the catwalk like only she can
yes
there's kim looking chic as she walks
the runway at the valenciaga show she's
in a skin-tight asymmetrical gown with
attached gloves paired with leggings
that have built in heels
[Music]
as one of valenciaga's muses we have to
say this entire moment is major kim took
to instagram to share her excitement
writing omg a dream come true
she also gushed over this being her
first paris fashion show and a couture
show at that it's so crazy but the
beauty mogul wasn't the only star
strutting in style
do aleppo wowed in a yellow one shoulder
mini gown with black gloves and a
slicked back ponytail
then there's nicole kidman and selling
sunset star christine quinn rocking
stunning silver creations
[Music]
of course bella hadid was in her element
slaying in a strapless emerald green
gown with a dramatic full skirt in the
front and a surprise mini skirt in the
back and turning heads left and right
supermodel naomi campbell
[Music]
she looked like a real-life queen
strutting in a black couture ball gown
one of the final looks from the show i
love
changing my look
and i love becoming characters
in pictures where i look completely
unlike myself i find it much more fun we
still can't get over kim making her big
debut and neither can her famous fam
[Applause]
kim's biggest fans her mom kris jenner
and nine-year-old daughter northwest who
were seated front row and looks like
north is taking after both her parents
as a fashionista in the making she's a
gemini so she's a little bit of both
after the show kim was seen hand in hand
with northey in shades and all black
ensembles
and when they first landed in paris
north channeled her dad kanye west in an
upcycled fit from his past it's
extremely important to me check out
north sporting her dad's royal blue
letterman jacket from yay's line pastel
it's the same look the rapper wore in
2008 at the american music awards the
father-daughter resemblance is uncanny
she definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality maybe one day north will
rock a runway like her mama but for now
we are living for kim in couture
[Music]
you